and a Tony goes to Brandon uranowitz
Samuel L Jackson and Aaron Rodgers go
viral after attending the Tony Awards on
Sunday night
offering the internet some meme worthy
moments I try wow Leah Michelle Wows
with her performance from funny girl
getting ready for me
first up Samuel who was nominated for
best lead actor in a play for his
performance in August Wilson's the piano
lesson would you be surprised how many
people trying to go north get on the
train going west the Hollywood icon
ultimately lost and it was the face he
made as the Winner's name was announced
that instantly had people chatting
online and a Tony goes to
Brandon uranowitz Leopold Style
yeah the Tony went to Brandon uranowitz
for his role in leopoldstadt this is
unbelievable Samuel's expression was
giving major sad Vibes and thus amim was
born
pretty high for the rest of us but
Samuel was in on the joke and poked
funded himself a little later in the
night when he and his wife Latonya
Richardson Jackson presented the award
for best play I Am Samuel Ellison
honored to be nominated Jackson
yeah truly an honor for the first time
Tony nominee to learn from everything
then there's Aaron Rodgers whose
appearance on Broadway's biggest night
went viral after he was spotted looking
super confused in the audience and fans
were just as perplexed wondering why the
NFL quarterback who was recently traded
to the New York Jets was there if I had
to guess it was probably that whole New
York thing
one person tweeted sorry did I just see
Aaron Rodgers at the Tonys while another
wrote Aaron Rodgers jump scare at the
Tonys was absolutely not necessary
[Applause]
but before that moment on the broadcast
Aaron posed it up with his teammate CJ
uzama on the red carpet this is you know
a little out of my element and while he
might have been out of his element Leah
Michelle was in hers delivering a
show-stopping rendition of Don't Rain on
My Parade live on stage
[Applause]
I think that everybody has wanted this
show to come back for so long I'm a huge
fan and always have been the performance
comes 10 months after Leah took over as
Fannie Bryce a role previously played by
beanie feldstein in the 2022 Broadway
Revival
is it my year since taking the stage in
the lead role the Glee Alum has earned
critical Acclaim for her performance
with many feelings she deserves Awards
recognition even though Replacements
don't qualify for most stage in theater
honors I couldn't be more excited about
it and while she may not have been up
for a Tony Leah was feeling the love
closing out the show with a standing o
[Music]
thank you